so there's a guy named elon musk
and he has a company in one of the many
companies called neuralink
that has uh that's also excited about
the brain
so be interesting to hear your kind of
opinions about a very different approach
that's invasive
that requires surgery that implants
a data collection device in the brain
how do you think about the difference
between kernel and neural link
in the approaches of getting that stream
of brain data
yeah elon and i spoke about this a lot
early on
we we met up i had started colonel and
he had an interest in pre-interfaces as
well
and we explored doing something together
him joining kernel and
ultimately it wasn't the right move and
so he started neurolink and i continued
building colonel
but it was interesting because we were
both
at this very early time where
wasn't certain what if there was a path
to pursue
if now was the right time to do
something and then the technological
choice of doing that and so
we were both our starting point was
looking at invasive technologies
and i was building invasive technology
at the time
that's ultimately where he's gone a
little less than a year after
elon and i were engaged i shifted kernel
to do non-invasive
and we had this neuroscientist come to
colonel we were talking about he had
been doing neurosurgery for 30 years one
of the most respected neuroscientists in
the us
and we brought him to colonel to figure
out the ins and outs of his profession
and at the very end of our three-hour
conversation he said
you know every 15 or so years
a new technology comes along that
changes everything
he said it's probably already here you
just can't see it yet
and my jaw dropped i thought because i i
had spoken to bob greenberg
who had built a second site first on the
optical nerve and then he did court up
an array on the optical
cortex and then i also uh became
friendly with um
neural pace who did who does the
implants for seizure detection
and remediation and
i saw in our in their eyes what it was
like to take something through an
implantable device through
for for a 15-year run they initially
thought in seven years
and ended up being 15 years and they
thought it'd be 100 million is you know
300 400 million
and i really didn't want to build
invasive technology
it was the only thing that appeared to
be possible but then once
i spun up an internal effort to start
looking at non-invasive options we said
is there something here is there
anything here that again has the
characteristics of
it has the high quality data it could be
low cost it could be accessible could it
make brain interfaces mainstream
and so i did a bet the company move we
shifted from non-invasive to
invasive to non-invasive so the answer
is yes to that there is something there
it's possible uh the answer is we'll see
we've now built both technologies
and they're now you experience one of
them today
we were applying
we're now deploying it so we're trying
to figure out what value is really there
but i'd say it's really too early to
express confidence
whether it's i think it's too early to
assess which technological choice
is the right one on what time skills
yeah time skills are really important
here very important because if you look
at the like on the invasive side
there's so much activity going on right
now of
less invasive techniques to get at
the neuron firings which would what
neural link is building
it's possible that in 10 15 years when
they're scaling that technology
other things come along and you'd much
rather do that that thing
starts to clock again it may not be the
case it may be the case that neural link
has properly chosen the right technology
and that that's exactly what they want
to be totally possible and it's also
possible that the paths we've chosen are
non-invasive
fall short for a variety of reasons it's
just it's unknown
and so right now the two technologies we
chose the analogy i'd give to
give you to create a baseline of
understanding is
if you think of it like the internet in
the 90s
the internet became useful when people
could do a dial-up connection
and then the page and then as as
bandwidth increased so did the utility
of that connection and so the ecosystem
improve
and so if you say what kernel flow uh
is going to give you a full screen on
the picture of information
but as you're going to be watching a
movie but the image is going to be
blurred
and the audio is going to be muffled so
it has a lower resolution of coverage
kernel flux our mg technology is going
to give you the full movie
in 1080p okay and
neuralink is going to give you a circle
on the screen of 4k okay
and so each one has their pros and cons
and
uh it's give and take and so the
decision i made
like kernel was that these two
technologies flux and flow
were basically the answer for the next
seven years yeah
and they would give rise to the
ecosystem which would become much more
valuable than the hardware itself
and that we would just continue to
improve on the hardware over time
and you know it's early days so it's
kind of fascinating to think about that
you don't it's it's very true that you
don't know
uh both paths are very prom
are promising
and it's like 50 years from now
we will look back and maybe not even
remember one of them
and the other one might change the world
it's so cool how technology is i mean
that's
that's what entrepreneurship is is like
mar it's the
the zeroth principle is like you're
marching ahead into the darkness into
the fog
not knowing it's wonderful to have
someone else out there with us doing
this
because if you if you look at brainerd
faces
anything that's off the shelf right now
is inadequate it's had its run for
a couple decades it's still in hacker
communities it hasn't gone to the
mainstream
the room size machines are on their own
path
but there is no answer right now of
bringing brain interfaces
mainstream and so it both
you know both they and us we've both
spent over 100 million dollars
and that's kind of what it takes to have
a go at this
because you need to build full stack
meaning that kernel
we are from the photon and the atom
through the machine learning
we have just under 100 people i think
it's something like 36
37 phds in these specialties
these areas that there's only a few
people in the world who have these
abilities
and that's what it takes to build next
generation have to
make an attempt at breaking into brain
interfaces
and so we'll see over the next couple
years whether it's the right time or
whether we're both too early
or whether something else comes along in
seven to ten years which is the right
thing that brings it mainstream so you
see elon is the kind of competitor
or a fellow traveler
along the path of uncertainty or both
it's a fellow traveler
it's like at the beginning of the
internet is
how many companies are going to be
invited to
this new ecosystem
like an endless number because if you
think that the hardware
just starts the process and so if you
okay back to your initial example if you
take the fitbit for example you say okay
now i can get
measurements on the body and what do we
think the ultimate value of this device
is going to be what is the information
transfer rate
and they were in the market for a
certain duration of time and google
bought them for
two and a half billion dollars they
didn't have ancillary value add there
weren't people building on top of
the fitbit device they also didn't have
increased
insight with additional data streams so
it's really just the device
if you look for example at apple and the
device they sell you have value in the
device that someone buys but also
you have everyone who's building on top
of it so you have this additional
ecosystem value and then you have
additional data streams that come in
which increase the value of the product
and so if you say if you look at the the
hardware
as the instigator of value creation
you know over time it what we've built
may constitute five or ten percent of
the value of the overall ecosystem and
that's what we
really care about what we're trying to
do is kick-start the mainstream adoption
of quantifying the brain and the
hardware
just opens the door to say what kind of
ecosystem could exist
and that's why we the examples are so
relevant of the things you've outlined
in your life
we hope i hope those things the books
people write
the experiences people build the
conversations you have your relationship
with your ai
systems i hope those all are feeding on
the insights
built upon this ecosystem we've created
to better your life and so that's
the thinking behind it again with the
drake equation being the underlying
driver of value and you know the people
at colonel have joined
not because we have certainty of
success but because we find it to be the
most exhilarating opportunity we could
ever pursue
in this time to be alive
you